il se décrit comme un charognard
beaucoup cela est lauréat du prix daniel
honoré 2020 est un ambassadeur de la
langue créole à l'encan etc les démos
chantant des mots virevoltant ici au
tampon
[Musique]
oui
merci vous cela y accueillait nantes et
à l'art alors la réunion les décrit
comme une île des poètes est ce qu'on
considère à eau comme à pau est est ce
que me considère pas comme un poète
on commence par considère manquant un
peu comme un poète quand on a demandé la
diamants d'un mois ça peut être mais ça
va et rien que le mot
embrasser bon paquet embalo rien
réunionnais l'inspecteur sam à mon ego
vous l'a remporté le prix l'ancrage
daniel honoré d'année dernière avec un
texte m'avait l'âme qu'on saute et
raconta nolad dans l'idée d'en m'avait
l'âme c'était d'aller faire une plongée
dans ce que nous les dans les strates
immémorial de d'un monde
en fin de compte et d'essayer d'aller
exhumé ou déterrer un a fait mais qui ça
qui remonte presque aux origines de
l'humanité novedia et après comme on l'a
mûri le projet comme on la travaille la
dure combien de temps le travail
d'écriture depuis à avoir l'idée
commence écrire et c'est à l'âge de deux
ans le l'aventuré chef dire parce que
j'avais envie d'écrire un texte que ce
serait comme une seule phrase que ce
serait comme un coup de locaux à lunel
choix c est lui arrive à la main et deir
alla caudron delame
depuis fin fonds auront fait clé était
temps les airs jusqu'à très fort on y
fait noir intense au fond elle n'a
daniel moussala diament goût cela et
comme à l'aller au texte ne va pas
comprendre rien c'est comme s'ils me
convenait plus mon langue n'a pas
compris que vous voulez dire qu'il n'ya
vous que aussi mal écrit dans une idée
d'amen la langue créole un hack
l'endroit après ouroboros barbara robin
avait déjà -1 me trouver comme si on
n'était pas allé assez loin donc ben
voilà travail à moins travailler ma et
dont ben mahdi ben allez allons voir où
ça nous peur emmène le ballon
la peau colère aster on pète kravis
rhône l'une l'autre noir mardi soir à
vinh
dans ma ville hamnett contraintes que
madame est à moi par exemple à 24 ans et
plus au présent mais ne connais pas trop
parce que napoléon n'a pas l'âme à du
temps de maintenant mal à enlever plein
de mots les comme un texte intemporel
tous des fois ce qui permet la
compréhension des femmes à l'enlever et
moi la coller tout des failles marché
des fois ils mangent pas et à côté
expérience comme ça ou donnerez comme
conseil assati veut très gentille est un
concours comme ça où tout simplement
satie vais écrire entre ce le conseil
c'est d'être les sentiers ou libre
sentiers libre d'exprimer à autre
manière dans le clan ce qu'on ressent ce
que vous vivre ce que vous pensez que
vous magie ce que et donc n'a point de
frappe pour écrire en créole c'est un
truc qui peut nier naturellement non les
parents n'est pas simple n'est pas sympa
débloquer parce que justement nous nenê
à notre culture notre éducation qui fait
que notre langue n'est pas elle n'est
pas libre forcément oui nous un
département français oui nous fait
partie de la france mais nous narre
cette identité de l'océan indien que
saâd et ben tiens pas nous savons que
cela pousse à écrire au tout début
pensez à theix l'amour voilà c'est ça
séoul est amoureux et là où commence ou
là notamment un spectacle rêves 40 oui
il qu'aux raconte de rêve car c'est
l'histoire d'un dessinateur et gagne pas
de sommeil et dansons l'insomnie lui
faire part est un musicien les fait
apparaître un boogie cause
et lui exprime ait les quartiers hauts
le coeur
[Musique]
grass valley coeur des cieux pas le
coeur du sundgau à l'eau son teaser
comédiens ont eux aussi dans la musique
c'est quoi ou de projets là on a deux
trois bulle de rêve y apparaît comme ça
passe par là dedans entend continuer à
écrire et continuer le chemin quoi
encore pleine bulle de rêve
ouais ouais merci beaucoup goose l'aiba
avec plaisir